[Music]
this next question comes from may
headley good evening
i would like to learn more about
re-baptism
i was baptized 13 years ago since then i
have fallen and even turned away from
god all right but i have returned each
time and recommitted my life and since
then i have definitely grown and and
practicing being in his word daily that
i may have power to stand
i am now active in my church i would
like to know
if i am to be re-baptized i do not want
to miss out on the kingdom of glory what
are reasons that would call for
re-baptism
if i recall directly you said she said i
i left god did she say that read the
beginning again i think she said she
left god
yes yes he's even turned away i've
fallen and even turned away from god
you've got to come back the same way you
came the first time re-baptism is
absolutely appropriate for someone who
faced that description the apostle paul
in acts 19 met 12 disciples who had been
baptized under the baptism of john
and he said have you ever heard of the
holy spirit and said we've never heard
of him john paul said what he taught
them then they were re-baptized i think
in verse
five or six seven acts 19 they were all
re-baptized evangelism page 375 when a
soul is truly reconverted let that soul
be re-baptized let him renew his
covenant with god and god will renew his
covenant with him reconversion must take
place in the churches and so based on
what i've read what i've heard that
person should consider re-baptism yes
because you turned away from god now
you're coming back coming back does not
require a different route the same
original rule you need to be re-baptized
but go to god psalm 32 verse 8 i will
instruct thee and teach the in the way
which thou shalt go let the lord convict
you but based on what you've said you
should be re-baptized
it is absolutely biblical
amen
there are a lot of people who need to be
re-baptized
they've walked with god so or they've
walked with the church but no growth i
mean 25 years 30 years have not grown an
inch they're the same people they were
at baptism as they are 30 years later
that person needs to start all over
start all over and get it right this
time with god's help
too many times we confuse church
membership with a relationship with
christ
more people are committed to the church
than they are to jesus
that's when the church treats them badly
they leave the church
but you don't leave jesus when you know
who jesus is and what he's done for you
commit to christ and someone who's been
committed to the church all these years
not to christ
really needs to be baptized
start all over again
amen sister sister kimberly peters is
putting in the chat that's right
you